Voya. Be confident to and
through retirement.
MARIA: WELCOME BACK PRESIDENT
TRUMP DECLARING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, OVER CORONAVIRUS IN
ORDER TO EXPEDITE RELIEF AID AND
TESTING TO STATES NEARLY 3,000
CASES IN 49 STATES, SO FAR WEST
VIRGINIA IS THE ONLY STATE NOT
REPORTING ANY CASES OF COVID-19.
AT LEAST 57 AMERICANS HAVE DIED,
AS THE HOUSE PASSES A BIPARTISAN
AID PACKAGE TO EASE THE ECONOMIC
FALLOUT.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS
CONGRESSMAN DEVON NUNES RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, HE’S ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE HOUSE WAYS AND MEANS
COMMITTEE AND CONGRESSMAN IT’S
GOOD TO HAVE YOU THIS MORNING.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU MARIA
THANK YOU.
MARIA: I WANT TO GET INTO REALLY
YOUR INVESTIGATION INTO CHINA,
WHICH GOES BACK YEARS, WHICH YOU
AND I HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT IN THE
PAST, BUT FIRST GIVE US YOUR
TAKE ON THE ADMINISTRATION’S
RESPONSE TO CORONAVIRUS.
>> WELL MOST IMPORTANTLY, I
THINK WHAT AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND IS WE NEED TO STOP
PANICKING HERE, OKAY?
THERE’S NO SHORTAGE OF FOOD IN
THIS COUNTRY.
PEOPLE DON’T NEED TO GO TO THE
STORE AND FIGHT OVER A BOTTLE OF
WATER OR  TOILET PAPER.
I COME FROM THE BREAD BASKET OF
THE WORLD IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND WE WANT PEOPLE TO GO
OUT AND BUY FOOD BUT THERE’S NO
SHORTAGE OF FOOD.
THE MAIN THING THAT PEOPLE NEED
TO FOCUS ON IS JUST A COUPLE
ISSUES.
NUMBER ONE, IF YOU’RE SICK, AT
ALL, BE SMART.
STAY AWAY FROM PEOPLE.
NUMBER TWO, IF YOU KNOW SOMEONE
THAT IS SENIOR, OR  IF YOU HAVE
AN UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITION
ESPECIALLY WITH YOUR LUNGS, YOU
ARE AT HIGH RISK, SO WE NEED TO
FOCUS ALL OF OUR ENERGY, ON OUR
SENIOR POPULATION WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONCERNS,
AND THERE IS NO REASON, MARIA
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO BE
RUNNING TO THE GROCERY STORE, TO
BUY 27 BANKS OF TOILET PAPER.
OKAY?
MARIA: [LAUGHTER]
>> THERE’S NO SHORTAGE OF
TOILET PAPER, NO SHORTAGE OF
FOOD COMING FROM SOMEONE WHO WE
WANT YOU TO BUY FOOD.
MARIA: RIGHT, I UNDERSTAND.
>> AND I’LL SAY THIS TOO.
I’LL JUST SAY THIS TOO.
YOU WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY, AND WHERE THERE’S A
LOT OF CONCERNS WITH THE ECONOMY
HERE BECAUSE P.M. ARE SCARED TO
GO OUT BUT I WILL JUST SAY IF
YOU’RE HEALTHY, YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY IT’S A GREAT TIME TO JUST
GO OUT AND GO TO A LOCAL
RESTAURANT, LIKELY YOU CAN GET
IN EASILY.
LET’S NOT HURT THE WORKING
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY, THAT ARE
RELYING ON WAGES AND TIPS TO
KEEP THEIR SMALL BUSINESS GOING.
DON’T RUN TO THE GROCERY STORE
AND BUY, YOU KNOW, $4,000 OF
FOOD.
MARIA: THEY ARE CLEANING OFF THE
SHELVES.
WE WANT TO BE VERY SYMPATHETIC
TO WHAT’S GOING ON PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE IT STARTED IN WUHAN,
CHINA BUT WHY IS IT THAT SO MANY
OF THESE DISEASES, THESE
SICKNESSES ORIGINATE IN CHINA?
WHAT IS THE ISSUE THERE?
>> WELL AS YOU KNOW, WE’VE BEEN
LOOKING AT CHINA FOR A VERY LONG
TIME, THE REPUBLICANS ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
AND WE’RE ACTUALLY BUILDING
LEGISLATION NOW THAT’S BASED OFF
OF OUR INVESTIGATION THAT WE’VE
BEEN CONDUCTING FOR A WHILE, SO
LOOK, THE CHINESE, THEY ARE A
COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIP, AND I
WOULD JUST SAY IT’S PROBABLY AS
EASY AS THIS TO UNDERSTAND.
THEY ARE IN EFFICIENT, OKAY?
THEY CAN, THEY HAVE PEOPLE THAT
ARE UNDER AUTHORITARIAN CONTROL.
THINK ABOUT IT THE DOCTOR THAT
ACTUALLY WAS THE WHISTLEBLOWER
ON THIS ENDED UP DEAD, OKAY?
AND IF YOU LOOK BACK TO WHAT THE
CHINESE DID, BACK THEY
PROBABLY HAD THIS IN THE LATE
FALL, ESPECIALLY EARLY WINTER,
THEY DIDN’T, YOU KNOW INSTEAD OF
LIKE CALLING PEOPLE IN AND
LEARNING HOW TO HELP AND DEVELOP